it's a new iteration of the wii sports
series
[Music]
nintendo switch sports
please take a look
[Music]
here the sports included in the nintendo
switch sports game
you might recognize these three from
past wii sports games
tennis rally by gently swinging the
joy-con controller at the right time
[Music]
bowling
roll the ball straight ahead or give it
a little curve
and chambra
knock your opponent off the platform
while attacking and defending
plus three additional sports are joining
the lineup
[Music]
soccer
use a gigantic ball to make dynamic
plays
enjoy matches with joy-con controllers
to shoot and perform diving headers
by attaching a joy-con controller to the
leg strap accessory included with the
physical version of the game you can
play shootout mode with intuitive
kicking motions
badminton
control your shots left and right while
keeping the shuttlecock in the air
unleash powerful smash shots to gain the
upper hand
[Music]
finally volleyball
use a joy-con controller to serve
bump
set
and spike the ball
[Music]
the game supports local play with family
and friends on one nintendo switch
system as well as online play across all
sports
play against friends online
or opt for random matchmaking the more
you win the tougher the players you'll
face
[Music]
try taking on this challenge
[Music]
how was that since i'm already here i'd
like to show you some gameplay of one of
the newly added sports volleyball
mr takahashi oh
hello there everyone i'm yoshiaki
koizumi from nintendo wow mr koizumi i
can see you're ready to play
all right i'll play some volleyball
online together with mr koizumi do you
have your wrist strap ready
yes of course
i've got plenty of space around me as
well
all right let's start we'll be including
some live commentary throughout our
match
all right oh we're doing this uh
volleyball a newly added sport in
nintendo switch sports
what can we expect today from the
takahashi koizumi team
it's koizumi to serve with takahashi up
front
we begin with koizumi serving
how will the opposing team react
takahashi makes the block
another one's coming
koizumi saves it a setup in the air and
here comes the spike
the other team saves it and fights back
and they score
takahashi didn't quite get it in time
all right well it's okay it's okay the
game's not over
now the other team serves
koizumi receives it takahashi sets it up
and koizubi spikes but it goes right
towards the opponent
here's another attack now's their chance
they get the ball
and with the setup from koizumi
takahashi
scores they got a point with that fierce
spike
let's stop our match here after all we
were in the middle of a presentation
all right i'll be leaving now
that was an introduction to nintendo
switch sports
the game launches april 29th
we're planning a free update in the
summer that allows you to play soccer
matches with a joy-con controller and
the leg strap accessory you can use the
accessory to place shootout mode at
launch
in addition
we're also planning a second free update
this fall that lets you enjoy golf
[Music]
and now a request to everyone
to help ensure that you can all enjoy
playing online we'll be having an online
play test before the game launches to
evaluate various technical aspects
we definitely like to ask for your help
with this
the online playtest will only be
available for players with an active
nintendo switch online membership on the
dates shown on screen
for those of you interested please visit
the official nintendo website for more
details
thank you